[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
é muito difícil quando a gente não
consegue se comunicar na verdade quando
a gente não consegue compreender a
pessoa que está se comunicando
pois bem eu estava apresentando uma boa
noite pra vocês dizendo que o meu nome é
carlos em libras é esse aqui o meu sinal
eu estava me comunico não me comunicando
com vocês através da língua brasileira
de sinais libras que no brasil tem uma
lei que reconhece como a língua oficial
desde 2002 assim como o nosso português
mas nem sempre foi assim a história de
luta para o direito de se comunicar
através da língua de sinais
é uma história de muita luta e vários e
vários momentos foram bastante marcante
muito tristes da história de quem estava
lutando pela língua de sinais como 1880
em milão um evento que está marcado na
história das pessoas que estavam lutando
por isso ocorreu a conferência e
professores e educadores de pessoas
surdas lá na itália naquele momento
estava para ser discutido qual seria a
melhor abordagem a melhor metodologia da
educação da pessoa surda se era através
da organização ou seja você ensinar o
surdo a falar ou se seria através da
língua gestual como era conhecido
naquela época
depois de muita votação ficou definido
que estava proibido a educação de surdos
através da língua de sinais e foi muito
muito triste pra todos que estavam
buscando uma liberdade de comunicação
através da língua gestual então as
escolas estavam proibidos de usarem os
sinais da educação da pessoa surda por
muitas vezes as crianças que insistiam
em se comunicar em libras tinham as suas
mãos amarradas para trás para impedi-las
de se comunicar através da língua
gestual
no mundo são mais de 360 milhões de
pessoas com algum problema auditivo na
aqui no brasil são quase 10 milhões de
pessoas onde boa parte são surdos
severos sobre os totais que a grande
maioria deles se comunicam e depende da
comunicação
através da língua de sinais
a camila por exemplo a camisinha ela
nasceu surda com a surdez bilateral
profunda e à medida que o caminhão ia
crescendo
a mãe luciana muito esperançosa com a
ajuda de muitos fonoaudiólogos tentava
organizar a pequena camila muito também
pelo desconhecimento do problema ea cama
ele era uma criança bastante frustrada
esse problema de comunicação com 1 em
casa com a própria família sua mãe seu
pai deixava muito nervosa e muito
impaciente família foi crescendo e as
coisas não foram melhorando
claro foi então que a mãe luciana
naquele momento descobriu a escola que
tem uma proposta de ensino para pessoas
surdas
foi nesse momento que luciana ea camila
conheceu a língua brasileira de sinais
a cada ida na escola cada novo sinal que
camila aprendia e seus pais
consequentemente também aprendiam eles
iam aumentando seu vocabulário e de fato
conseguiram agora estabelecer um diálogo
família em casa mas o problema persistia
quando caminha precisava sair de casa as
pessoas não falavam libras seus
familiares não falavam em libras
os eventos sociais a onde luciana ea sua
filha as pessoas também não se falava em
libras e como é que essa história se
conecta com a história desses três
alagoanos
eu sou carlos informação em análise e
desenvolvimento de sistema o ronaldo que
está à minha direita é publicitário de
informação eo tadeu ele é arquiteto
ainda na faculdade de publicidade o
professor tenha passado a atividade que
era pra que os alunos criar se um
produto
naquela época o ronaldo
depois de muita pesquisa ele se
questionou por que a gente não pode usar
a tecnologia para melhorar a comunicação
entre surdos e ouvintes por ele ter
vindo do curso de ciência da computação
e tem uma base tecnológica
foi a pergunta naquele momento muito
simples pra ele e aí a idéia ficou
dominado por alguns anos porque foi
apenas para aquele momento na esplana
durante a formação dele até que em 2012
e fiz um curso de desenvolvimento de
aplicativos em belo horizonte quando
cheguei eu já trabalhava em alguns
projetos ronaldo disse ronaldo
é preciso pôr em prática agora e ele
ressurgiu com essa idéia
a gente começou viu que realmente a
oportunidade era um desafio tecnológico
ainda não pôs em prática não ver até
onde isso vai
só que a gente precisava de um artista
3d onde pudesse criar um personagem que
estaria ali no nosso produto no dia a
dia
é aí que entra o tadeu e um especialista
em modelagem animação de personagens com
experiência internacional inclusive fora
do país e surgiu dessa idéia dessa ideia
começou a mudar a vida da gente
foi aí que surgiu o hugo é o hugo ele a
outra peça desse quarteto ou ele tem
mãos grandes para facilitar a expressão
gestual uma cabeça enorme
desproporcional mas justamente para
facilitar a expressão facial
então a partir daquele momento a gente
tinha se um protótipo um protótipo onde
você pode escrever no seu celular
é um tradutor de bolso quando você pode
escrever ou falar e aí automaticamente o
hugo ele traduz isso eleva essa
informação e libras que a língua
brasileira de sinais utilizada pela
comunidade surda no brasil surgiu a
possibilidade de participar de um
desafio aqui em maceió chamado de modelo
alagoas um desafio do startup não fazia
a mínima noção de que a startup naquela
época então era apresentar o projeto
para uma banca de investidores tanto
aqui no brasil como de fora e nós
ganhamos com o maior projeto deste
evento o de modelar goa aqui nasceu foi
a primeira vez que aconteceu nesse
momento daqueles investidores que estava
avaliando a gente conversou com cinco
deles disseram não a gente quer que esse
protótipo realmente vira um produto a
gente quer abraçar a causa junto com
você recebeu investimento em agosto de
2012 e já em setembro a gente acaba
participando de um outro evento na no
rio de janeiro chamado rio info foi o
salão da inovação do rio onde ganhamos
com um projeto mais inovador do salão da
inovação
então com muito orgulho fiquei lá a
nossa bandeira a bandeira do nosso
estado porque nenhum projeto sequer quem
chega na final nenhum projeto do
nordeste nunca tinha chegado na final
deste evento e foi um dos momentos a
gente pensou assim poxa essa ideia que
ainda é um protótipo realmente ela
merece ser posto em prática no final de
2012 recebeu o convite quando ele foi
selecionado como um dos representantes
brasileiros e um evento chamado ws amou
que aconteceu em abu dhabi que é
considerado o oscar dos aplicativos
móveis em fevereiro de 2013 esses mesmos
três alagoanos desembarcavam em abu
dhabi participar de uma semana
totalmente diferente da nossa realidade
em abu dhabi é um lugar incrível
então nós disputamos na categoria de
acessibilidade inclusão com países que
investem milhões de dólares todos os
anos no momento da cerimônia no chamaram
e nós fomos considerado o melhor
aplicativo de inclusão social do mundo
pela onu
esse é um evento da onu
obrigado naquele momento mais uma vez
com a bandeira do nosso estado naquele
palco caiu a minha ficha não é aquela
pequena ideia ainda não era mais uma
ideia é um propósito de vida pra gente e
eu quero trazer a frase do grande
filósofo aqui que é o tio ben o tio de
uma aranha onde com grandes poderes vêm
grandes responsabilidades ainda éramos o
protótipo e não tínhamos o aplicativo na
loja em julho de 2013
a gente lançou esse aplicativo e com
eles
isso aí pessoal moral que a gente tem lá
no escritório nem compartilha feedbacks
e comentários de nossos usuários e ver a
satisfação de pessoas como a sabine
não é que tenham a criança surda que a
gente teve a oportunidade de conhecer o
guilherme o que hoje é um grande xodó
lado escritório eles são de são paulo
onde o gui
através desse homem hugo não aprende
novos sinais e aumenta o seu vocabulário
não são histórias como essa que a gente
recebe diariamente como chora do doutor
davi
todavia durante seu plantão no hospital
recebe uma jovem surda de 13 anos com a
sua mãe ea mãe dela não saber se
comunicar em libras
ele estava dentro de um problema ela
estava com fortes dores na cabeça e como
fazer agora pelo poder fazer um
diagnóstico básico com essa paciente
ele lembrou durante por causa dessa
grande exposição na mídia que teve então
lembrou do aplicativo
ele conseguiu fazer um diagnóstico
básico com o protocolo básico de
atendimento
ele percebeu que alguma coisa errada ele
encaminhou a jovem para o setor de
neurologia não foi identificado um
sangramento intracraniano e ela foi
submetida a cirurgia imediatamente o
doutor davi
ele foi muito enfático quando ele disse
que o gol ajudou realmente é salvar a
vida dessa jovem
até hoje me arrepio a dizer isso porque
isso é só um tipo de comentário que a
gente recebe todos os dias nós
costumamos dizer que afirmam que em
troca ela não é simplesmente a
plataforma tradução
ela trabalha o relacionamento e as
relações entre as pessoas com uma
história da própria camila em sua mãe
luciana que agora consegue realmente
uma comunicação mãe filha e toda essa
exposição leva gente é esse número hoje
atual da em tóquio onde mais de um
milhão de pessoas já baixaram o
aplicativo irá baixar o hub podem contar
com o ovo no seu dia a dia seja para
aprender libras seja para a inter se
interessar pela língua de sinais que é
um grande papel também da retoque é
mostrar e exibir essa cultura surda só
quer a pontinha do iceberg
um outro problema o outro porque é as
pessoas surdas
a grande maioria tem extrema dificuldade
de comunicar em português ou seja ler e
escrever em português
então como levar essa informação no
mundo digital quanto o conteúdo online
no hawai vasto conteúdo online na língua
de sinais de surdos
então a gente desenvolveu uma outra
solução um simples botão um simples
botão no site
ao ser ativada você leva toda essa
informação na língua oficial do surdo
então o hugo tá ajudando a levar todo
esse vasto conteúdo quando falo com 11
um produto para tradutores haiti e saiu
sem incluir sistemas de ensino a
distância sistema de intranet como a
gente tem da natura para ajudar o
treinamento ea capacitação das pessoas
que trabalham lá com toda essa exposição
fomos escolhidos não em 2014 como
empreendedores sociais de futuro pela
folha shopping foundation uma fundação
preocupada e que valoriza as soluções de
impacto social no país em 2015
lá em medellín uma das cidades mais
inovadores do mundo considerado em 2013
nós tivemos há a possibilidade de
receber mais um outro prêmio da onu como
o melhor aplicativo de inclusão social
da américa latina e caribe e finalmente
uma das histórias mais marcantes retoque
é que o google
ele conheceu o hugo ou seja final do ano
passado fomos onde startup brasileiras
escolhidas para participar de um
programa de aceleração do google que
durou seis meses
tão logo após o réveillon no início
deste ano
estávamos desembarcando em são francisco
onde passamos praticamente os 15
primeiros dias morando dentro do google
tendo mentoria e capacitação com os
principais engenheiros de tecnologia que
trabalham lá no google com pessoas de
negócio com investidores do vale do
silício
então tudo isso foi muito importante
naquele momento a gente criar um produto
mais forte
mudar uma base tecnológica da gente pra
aguentar os planos que a gente tem agora
para 2017 2006 foi incrível foi o melhor
ano disparado da retorta então outro
levantamento que a gente fez é só as
principais cidades onde a gente tem
usuários ativos em tóquio foi baixado no
brasil inteiro e o que a gente quer é
levar esse impacto que a gente tem aqui
no brasil para outro lugar do mundo
porque a libras a língua brasileira de
sinais
existem mais de 200 língua de sinais no
mundo todo e todos também dependem da
comunicação em língua de sinais para se
comunicar com o hugo já está estudando
né
o google costuma dizer que ele é nosso
produto a gente é o aplicativo
tradutores haiti é verdade mas o produto
é o uec está no dia-a-dia da plataforma
são que mudou então assim como a camila
ea luciana hoje já uma moça quando você
anda nos mandou esse relato da amizade
de sua filha dela congo para aprender
novos sinais é isso nos comove bastante
aquela ideia aqueles porque isso que a
gente fazia lá no início de 2012
hoje realmente impacto na vida de
milhões de pessoas e é isso que a gente
precisa voltar a ser pessoal aquela
criança pequena é seu pai e seu pai de
três meninos
então como é que criança quando pequena
curiosa descobrindo o mundo questionando
de tudo sobretudo por causa de tudo
então a gente não fez nada diferente
disso disse questionado e não ficar no
nosso lugar na nossa zona de conforto e
querer realmente unir o nosso
conhecimento é algo pudesse causar um
impacto social
eu acho que a gente não devem porque a
gente precisa esperar a vida passar pela
gente sem ser protagonista dessa
história e contribuir com a sociedade de
alguma forma
é verdade então um dos momentos que me
deixa com maior orgulho meu sócio
ronaldo meu amigo meu irmão mês
retrasado agora foi considerado pelo
embate com um dos 35 jovens mais
inovadores do mundo alagoano trabalhar o
meu lado
então o e marquinhos e viu é uma
premiação global já revelou pessoas como
steve jobs premiou pessoas como steve
jobs mark zuckeberg e agora o meu amigo
irmão ronaldo que na hora da verdade
está se questionando a respeito dessas
coisas porque não porque o fato de a
gente estar em alagoas é um impeditivo
por exemplo uma solução de impacto
nacional e global
diogo 2017 já falei vai aprender novas
línguas de sinais
então a gente está trabalhando para
agora no próximo ano e começar a
internacionalização da ren toque
então toda essa história que compartilho
com vocês agora é apenas o primeiro
capítulo do que a gente espera que seja
um toque nos próximos anos
de verdade sabe a gente faz com muito
orgulho e quando olha para essa foto
daquele dia 3 de agosto de 2012
mas só essa jornada esse filme que vem à
minha cabeça mas é o legado a
importância do legado não somente
tecnológico mas o legado de quebra
paradigmas e mudar essa mentalidade de
que a gente acaba se substimando por
está isolado dos grandes centros
então esse legado que a gente deixa ele
é tão importante quanto a tecnologia que
a gente está desenvolvendo
principalmente aqui no meu estado é um
estado que eu amo e que sou apaixonada
então quando a idéia de transformar de
verdade no propósito você muda o mundo
você você você vocês e vocês mudam o
mundo tão mudem também vocês o mundo
pra finalizar para fraseando grande
quebrando o protocolo mais uma vez
eu trago essa bandeira com muito orgulho
que é a mesma das fotos que vocês viram
para mostrar o potencial da idéia então
sejam vocês a mudança que vocês querem
ver no mundo
[Aplausos]